les manifestations populaires de ces
derniers mois n'ont fait qu'affaiblir le
parti islamiste rendu responsable par
une majeure partie de la population
tunisienne de la crise politique et
économique et gangrène le pays depuis la
révolution de 2011 le parti qui dénoncé
un coup d'état constitutionnel
comptant sur l'appui des américains pour
maintenir son hégémonie dans le pays
semble plus que jamais isolé certains
membres du parti comme numéro 2 et
ancien premier ministre ali larayedh
n'ont pas hésité à rejeter la
responsabilité sur rached ghannouchi
leur chef de file et président du
parlement entre crises nationales et
crise en interne les islamistes n'ont
plus d'autre choix que de mettre de
l'eau dans leur vin depuis plusieurs
mois ennahda demeure dans le viseur du
président de la république yayi sayed
qui n'a pas hésité lors d'une conférence
donnée à l'occasion d'une campagne aide
aux plus démunis à les nommer
directement suite aux nombreuses menaces
reçus au palais de carthage comment
peuvent-ils atteindre la réputation des
hommes et des femmes il considère que
les mensonges font partie des outils
politiques
je suis au courant de ce qu'il manigance
je leur dis que je n'ai peur que de dieu
malgré leurs tentatives misérable il
pense au meurtre et aux assassinats dans
l'embarras ennahda a aussitôt réagi en
condamnant fermement ces menaces et en
apportant leur soutien au président de
la république dans ce communiqué rendu
public dimanche ennahda a appelé à
éviter tout discours incitant à la
mobilisation la provocation et la
violence soulignant la nécessité de
respecter les institutions de l'état
dont en premier lieu celle de la
présidence de la république le parti n'a
pas hésité à réitérer dans ce communiqué
son attachement au dialogue pour
surmonter la crise actuelle en tunisie
un appel resté jusqu'ici ignoré par le
président de la république bien
déterminés à ne rien lâcher